the game wordle has gone pretty viral in
the last month or two and never one to
overlook an opportunity for a math
lesson it occurs to me that this game
makes for a very good central example in
a lesson about information theory and in
particular a topic known as entropy
you see like a lot of people i got kind
of sucked into the puzzle and like a lot
of programmers i also got sucked into
trying to write an algorithm that would
play the game as optimally as it could
and what i thought i'd do here is just
talk through with you some of my process
in that and explain some of the math
that went into it since the whole
algorithm centers on this idea of
entropy
first things first in case you haven't
heard of it what is wordle and to kill
two birds with one stone here while we
go through the rules of the game let me
also preview where we're going with this
which is to develop a little algorithm
that will basically play the game for us
so i haven't done today's wordle this is
february 4th and we'll see how the bot
does the goal of wordle is to guess a
mystery five-letter word and you're
given six different chances to guess for
example my wordlebot suggests that i
start with the guess crane
each time that you make a guess you get
some information about how close your
guess is to the true answer here the
gray box is telling me there's no c in
the actual answer the yellow box is
telling me there is an r but it's not in
that position the green box is telling
me that the secret word does have an a
and it's in the third position and then
there's no n and there's no e so let me
just go in and tell the word about that
information we started with crane we got
gray yellow green grey grey
don't worry about all the data that it's
showing right now i'll explain that in
due time but its top suggestion for our
second pick is schtick
and your guess does have to be an actual
five-letter word but as you'll see it's
pretty liberal with what it will
actually let you guess
in this case we try stick
and all right things are looking pretty
good we hit the s and the h so we know
the first three letters we know that
there's an r and so it's going to be
like s-h-a something r or
s-h-a-r-something
and it looks like the wordle-bot knows
that it's down to just two possibilities
either shard or sharp
that's kind of a toss-up between them at
this point so i guess probably just
because it's alphabetical it goes with
shard
which hooray is the actual answer so we
got it in three
if you're wondering if that's any good
the way i heard one person phrase it is
that with wordle four is par and three
is birdie which i think is a pretty apt
analogy you have to be consistently on
your game to be getting four but it's
certainly not crazy but when you get it
in three it just feels great
so if you're down for it what i'd like
to do here is just talk through my
thought process from the beginning for
how i approach the wordlebot and like i
said really it's an excuse for an
information theory lesson the main goal
is to explain what is information and
what is entropy
my first thought in approaching this was
to take a look at the relative
frequencies of different letters in the
english language
so i thought okay is there an opening
guess or an opening pair of guesses that
hits a lot of these most frequent
letters and one that i was pretty fond
of was doing other followed by nails
the thought is that if you hit a letter
you know you get a green or a yellow
that always feels good it feels like
you're getting information but in these
cases even if you don't hit and you
always get grays that's still giving you
a lot of information since it's pretty
rare to find a word that doesn't have
any of these letters but even still that
doesn't feel super systematic because
for example it does nothing to consider
the order of the letters why type nails
when i could type snail
is it better to have that s at the end
i'm not really sure
now a friend of mine said that he liked
to open with the word weary which kind
of surprised me because it has some
uncommon letters in there like the w and
the y
but who knows maybe that is a better
opener is there some kind of
quantitative score that we can give to
judge the quality of a potential guess
now to set up for the way that we're
going to rank possible guesses let's go
back and add a little clarity to how
exactly the game is set up so there's a
list of words that it will allow you to
enter that are considered valid guesses
that's just about 13 000 words long but
when you look at it there's a lot of
really uncommon things things like ahead
or ollie and arg the kind of words that
bring about family arguments in a game
of scrabble but the vibe of the game is
that the answer is always going to be a
decently common word and in fact there's
another list of around 2 300 words that
are the possible answers and this is a
human curated list i think specifically
by the game creator's girlfriend which
is kind of fun but what i would like to
do our challenge for this project is to
see if we can write a program solving
wordle that doesn't incorporate previous
knowledge about this list for one thing
there's plenty of pretty common five
letter words that you won't find in that
list though it would be better to write
a program that's a little more resilient
and would play wordle against anyone not
just what happens to be the official
website and also the reason that we know
what this list of possible answers is is
because it's visible in the source code
but the way that it's visible in the
source code is in the specific order in
which answers come up from day to day so
you could always just look up what
tomorrow's answer will be so clearly
there's some sense in which using the
list is cheating and what makes for a
more interesting puzzle and a richer
information theory lesson is to instead
use some more universal data like
relative word frequencies in general to
capture this intuition of having a
preference for more common words
so of these 13 000 possibilities how
should we choose the opening guess for
example if my friend proposes weary how
should we analyze its quality well the
reason he said he likes that unlikely w
is that he likes the long shot nature of
just how good it feels if you do hit
that w for example if the first pattern
revealed was something like this then it
turns out there are only 58 words in
this giant lexicon that match that
pattern so that's a huge reduction from
thirteen thousand but the flip side of
that of course is that it's very
uncommon to get a pattern like this
specifically if each word was equally
likely to be the answer the probability
of hitting this pattern would be 58
divided by around thirteen thousand
of course they're not equally likely to
be answers most of these are very
obscure and even questionable words but
at least for our first pass at all of
this let's assume that they're all
equally likely and then refine that a
bit later the point is the pattern with
a lot of information is by its very
nature unlikely to occur in fact what it
means to be informative is that it's
unlikely
a much more probable pattern to see with
this opening would be something like
this where of course there's not a w in
it maybe there's an e and maybe there's
no a there's no r there's no y
in this case there are fourteen hundred
possible matches so if all were equally
likely it works out to be a probability
of about eleven percent that this is the
pattern you would see so the most likely
outcomes are also the least informative
to get a more global view here let me
show you the full distribution of
probabilities across all of the
different patterns that you might see
so each bar that you're looking at
corresponds to a possible pattern of
colors that could be revealed of which
there are three to the fifth
possibilities and they're organized from
left to right most common to least
common so the most common possibility
here is that you get all grays that
happens about 14 percent of the time
and what you're hoping for when you make
a guess is that you end up somewhere out
in this long tail like over here where
there's only 18 possibilities for what
matches this pattern that evidently look
like this
or if we venture a little farther to the
left you know maybe we go all the way
over here
okay here's a good puzzle for you what
are the three words in the english
language that start with a w end with a
y and have an r somewhere in them turns
out the answers are let's see
wordy wormy and riley
so to judge how good this word is
overall we want some kind of measure of
the expected amount of information that
you're going to get from this
distribution if we go through each
pattern and we multiply its probability
of occurring times something that
measures how informative it is that can
maybe give us an objective score
now your first instinct for what that
something should be might be the number
of matches you know you want a lower
average number of matches but instead
i'd like to use a more universal
measurement that we often ascribe to
information and one that will be more
flexible once we have a different
probability assigned to each of these 13
000 words for whether or not they're
actually the answer
the standard unit of information is the
bit which has a little bit of a funny
formula but it's really intuitive if we
just look at examples
if you have an observation that cuts
your space of possibilities in half we
say that it has one bit of information
in our example the space of
possibilities is all possible words and
it turns out about half of the five
letter words have an s a little less
than that but about half
so that observation would give you one
bit of information
if instead a new fact chops down that
space of possibilities by a factor of
four we say that it has two bits of
information for example it turns out
about a quarter of these words have a t
if the observation cuts that space by a
factor of eight we say it's three bits
of information and so on and so forth
four bits cuts it into a sixteenth five
bits cuts it into a 30 second
so now it's when you might want to take
a moment and pause and ask for yourself
what is the formula for information for
the number of bits in terms of the
probability of an occurrence
well what we're saying here is basically
that when you take one half to the
number of bits that's the same thing as
the probability which is the same thing
as saying 2 to the power of the number
of bits is 1 over the probability which
rearranges further to saying the
information is the log base 2 of 1
divided by the probability and sometimes
you see this with one more rearrangement
still where the information is the
negative log base 2 of the probability
expressed like this it can look a little
bit weird to the uninitiated but it
really is just a very intuitive idea of
asking how many times you've cut down
your possibilities in half
now if you're wondering you know i
thought we were just playing a fun word
game why are logarithms entering the
picture one reason this is a nicer unit
is it just a lot easier to talk about
very unlikely events much easier to say
that an observation has 20 bits of
information than it is to say that the
probability of such and such occurring
is 0.000095
but a more substantive reason that this
logarithmic expression turned out to be
a very useful addition to the theory of
probability is the way that information
adds together for example if one
observation gives you two bits of
information cutting your space down by
four and then a second observation like
your second guess in wordle gives you
another three bits of information
chopping you down further by another
factor of eight the two together give
you five bits of information in the same
way that probabilities like to multiply
information likes to add
so as soon as we're in the realm of
something like an expected value where
we're adding a bunch of numbers up the
logs make it a lot nicer to deal with
let's go back to our distribution for
weary and add another little tracker on
here showing us how much information
there is for each pattern
the main thing i want you to notice is
that the higher the probability as we
get to those more likely patterns the
lower the information the fewer bits you
gain
the way we measure the quality of this
guess will be to take the expected value
of this information where we go through
each pattern we say how probable is it
and then we multiply that by how many
bits of information do we get
and in the example of weary that turns
out to be 4.9 bits so on average the
information you get from this opening
guess is as good as chopping your space
of possibilities in half about five
times by contrast an example of a guess
with a higher expected information value
would be something like slate
in this case you'll notice the
distribution looks a lot flatter in
particular the most probable occurrence
of all grays only has about a six
percent chance of occurring so at
minimum you're getting evidently 3.9
bits of information but that's a minimum
more typically you'd get something
better than that
and it turns out when you crunch the
numbers on this one and you add up all
of the relevant terms the average
information is about 5.8
so in contrast with weary your space of
possibilities will be about half as big
after this first guess on average
there's actually a fun story about the
name for this expected value of
information quantity you see information
theory was developed by claude shannon
who was working at bell labs in the
1940s but he was talking about some of
his yet to be published ideas with john
von neumann who was this intellectual
giant of the time very prominent in math
and physics and the beginnings of what
was becoming computer science and when
he mentioned that he didn't really have
a good name for this expected value of
information quantity but neumann
supposedly said so the story goes well
you should call it entropy and for two
reasons in the first place your
uncertainty function has been used in
statistical mechanics under that name so
it already has a name and in the second
place and more important nobody knows
what entropy really is so in a debate
you'll always have the advantage
so if the name seems a little bit
mysterious and if this story is to be
believed that's kind of by design
also if you're wondering about its
relation to all of that second law of
thermodynamics stuff from physics there
definitely is a connection but in its
origins shannon was just dealing with
pure probability theory and for our
purposes here when i use the word
entropy i just want you to think the
expected information value of a
particular guess
you can think of entropy as measuring
two things simultaneously the first one
is how flat is the distribution the
closer a distribution is to uniform the
higher that entropy will be
in our case where there are three to the
fifth total patterns for a uniform
distribution observing any one of them
would have information log base 2 of 3
to the fifth which happens to be 7.92 so
that is the absolute maximum that you
could possibly have for this entropy but
entropy is also kind of a measure of how
many possibilities there are in the
first place for example if you happen to
have some word where there's only 16
possible patterns and each one is
equally likely this entropy this
expected information would be four bits
but if you have another word where
there's 64 possible patterns that could
come up and they're all equally likely
then the entropy would work out to be
six bits
so if you see some distribution out in
the wild that has an entropy of six bits
it's sort of like it's saying there's as
much variation and uncertainty in what's
about to happen as if there were 64
equally likely outcomes
for my first pass at the world bot i
basically had it just do this it goes
through all of the different possible
guesses that you could have all 13 000
words it computes the entropy for each
one or more specifically the entropy of
the distribution across all patterns
that you might see for each one and then
it picks the highest since that's the
one that's likely to chop down your
space of possibilities as much as
possible
and even though i've only been talking
about the first guess here it does the
same thing for the next few guesses for
example after you see some pattern on
that first guess which would restrict
you to a smaller number of possible
words based on what matches with that
you just play the same game with respect
to that smaller set of words for a
proposed second guess you look at the
distribution of all patterns that could
occur from that more restricted set of
words
you search through all 13 000
possibilities and you find the one that
maximizes that entropy
to show you how this works in action let
me just pull up a little variant of
wordle that i wrote that shows the
highlights of this analysis in the
margins
so after doing all its entropy
calculations on the right here it's
showing us which ones have the highest
expected information turns out the top
answer at least at the moment we'll
refine this later is tares
which means
um
of course
avetch the most common vetch
each time we make a guess here where
maybe i kind of ignore its
recommendations and go with slate
because i like slate we can see how much
expected information it had but then on
the right of the word here it's showing
us how much actual information we got
given this particular pattern so here it
looks like we were a little unlucky we
were expected to get 5.8 but we happened
to get something with less than that and
then on the left side here it's showing
us all of the different possible words
given where we are now
the blue bars are telling us how likely
it thinks each word is so at the moment
it's assuming each word is equally
likely to occur but we'll refine that in
a moment
and then this uncertainty measurement is
telling us the entropy of this
distribution across the possible words
which right now because it's a uniform
distribution is just a needlessly
complicated way to count the number of
possibilities for example if we were to
take 2 to the power of 13.66
that should be around the 13 000
possibilities
a little bit off here but only because
i'm not showing all the decimal places
at the moment that might feel redundant
and like it's overly complicating things
but you'll see why it's useful to have
both numbers in a minute so here it
looks like it's suggesting the highest
entropy for our second guess is ramen
which again just really doesn't feel
like a word so
to take the moral high ground here i'm
going to go ahead and type in rains
and again it looks like we were a little
unlucky we were expecting 4.3 bits and
we only got 3.39 bits of information so
that takes us down to 55 possibilities
and here maybe i'll just actually go
with what it's suggesting which is kombu
whatever that means
and okay this is actually um a good
chance for a puzzle it's telling us this
pattern gives us 4.7 bits of information
but over on the left before we see that
pattern there were 5.78 bits of
uncertainty so as a quiz for you what
does that mean about the number of
remaining possibilities
well it means that we're reduced down to
one bit of uncertainty which is the same
thing as saying that there's two
possible answers it's a 50 50 choice
and from here because you and i know
which words are more common we know that
the answer should be abyss but as it's
written right now the program doesn't
know that so it just keeps going trying
to gain as much information as it can
until it's only one possibility left and
then it guesses it so obviously we need
a better endgame strategy but let's say
we call this version one of our wordle
solver and then we go and run some
simulations to see how it does
so the way this is working is it's
playing every possible wordle game it's
going through all of those 2315 words
that are the actual wordle answers it's
basically using that as a testing set
and with this naive method of not
considering how common a word is and
just trying to maximize the information
at each step along the way until it gets
down to one and only one choice
by the end of the simulation the average
score works out to be about 4.124
which
you know it's not bad to be honest i
kind of expected to do worse but the
people who play wordle will tell you
that they can usually get it in four the
real challenge is to get as many in
three as you can it's a pretty big jump
between the score four and the score of
three
the obvious low-hanging fruit here is to
somehow incorporate whether or not a
word is common and how exactly do we do
that
[Music]
the way i approached it is to get a list
of the relative frequencies for all of
the words in the english language and i
just used mathematica's word frequency
data function which itself pulls from
the google books english ngram public
dataset and it's kind of fun to look at
for example if we sorted from the most
common words to the least common words
evidently these are the most common five
letter words in the english language or
rather these is the eighth most common
first is which after which there's there
and there first itself is not first but
ninth and it makes sense that these
other words could come about more often
where those after first are after where
and those being just a little bit less
common
now in using this data to model how
likely each of these words is to be the
final answer it shouldn't just be
proportional to the frequency because
for example which is given a score of
0.002 in this data set whereas the word
braid is in some sense about a thousand
times less likely but both of these are
common enough words that they're almost
certainly worth considering so we want
more of a binary cutoff
the way i went about it is to imagine
taking this whole sorted list of words
and then arranging it on an x-axis and
then applying the sig point function
which is the standard way to have a
function whose output is basically
binary it's either zero or it's one but
there's a smoothing in between for that
region of uncertainty
so essentially the probability that i'm
assigning to each word for being in the
final list will be the value of the
sigmoid function above wherever it sits
on the x-axis
now obviously this depends on a few
parameters for example how wide a space
on the x-axis those words fill
determines how gradually or steeply we
drop off from one to zero and where we
situate them left to right determines
the cut off and to be honest the way i
did this was kind of just licking my
finger and sticking it into the wind i
looked through the sordid list and tried
to find a window where when i looked at
it i figured about half of these words
are more likely than not to be the final
answer and use that as the cutoff
now once we have a distribution like
this across the words it gives us
another situation where entropy becomes
this really useful measurement for
example let's say we were playing a game
and we start with my old openers which
were other end nails and we end up with
a situation where there's four possible
words that match it and let's say we
consider them all equally likely
let me ask you what is the entropy of
this distribution
well the information associated with
each one of these possibilities is going
to be the log base 2 of four since each
one is one and four and that's two it's
two bits of information four
possibilities all very well and good
but what if i told you that actually
there's more than four matches in
reality when we look through the full
word list there are 16 words that match
it but suppose our model puts a really
low probability on those other 12 words
of actually being the final answer
something like one in a thousand because
they're really obscure
now let me ask you what is the entropy
of this distribution
if entropy was purely measuring the
number of matches here then you might
expect it to be something like the log
base 2 of 16 which would be four two
more bits of uncertainty than we had
before but of course the actual
uncertainty is not really that different
from what we had before because just
because there's these 12 really obscure
words doesn't mean that it would be all
that more surprising to learn that the
final answer is charm for example
so when you actually do the calculation
here and you add up the probability of
each occurrence times the corresponding
information what you get is 2.11 bits
just saying it's basically two bits it's
basically those four possibilities but
there's a little more uncertainty
because of all of those highly unlikely
events though if you did learn them
you'd get a ton of information from it
so zooming out this is part of what
makes wordle such a nice example for an
information theory lesson we have these
two distinct feeling applications for
entropy the first one telling us what's
the expected information we'll get from
a given guess and the second one saying
can we measure the remaining uncertainty
among all of the words that we have
possible
and i should emphasize in that first
case where we're looking at the expected
information of a guess once we have an
unequal waiting to the words that
affects the entropy calculation for
example let me pull up that same case we
were looking at earlier of the
distribution associated with weary but
this time using a non-uniform
distribution across all possible words
so let me see if i can find a part here
that illustrates it pretty well
uh okay here this is pretty good here we
have two adjacent patterns that are
about equally likely but one of them
we're told has 32 possible words that
match it and if we check what they are
these are those 32 which are all just
very unlikely words as you scan your
eyes over them it's hard to find any
that feel like plausible answers maybe
yells but if we look at the neighboring
pattern in the distribution which is
considered just about as likely we're
told that it only has eight possible
matches so a quarter as many matches but
it's about as likely and when we pull up
those matches we can see why some of
these are actual plausible answers like
ring or wrath or wraps
to illustrate how we incorporate all
that let me pull up version 2 of the
wordlebot here and there are two or
three main differences from the first
one that we saw first off like i just
said the way that we're computing these
entropies these expected values of
information is now using the more
refined distributions across the
patterns that incorporates the
probability that a given word would
actually be the answer
as it happens tares is still number one
though the ones following are a bit
different second when it ranks its top
picks it's now going to keep a model of
the probability that each word is the
actual answer and it'll incorporate that
into its decision which is easier to see
once we have a few guesses on the table
again ignoring its recommendation
because we can't let machines rule our
lives
and i suppose i should mention another
thing different here is over on the left
that uncertainty value that number of
bits is no longer just redundant with
the number of possible matches now if we
pull it up and you know we calculated
say 2 to the 8.02 which would be a
little above 256 i guess 259 what it's
saying is even though there are 526
total words that actually match this
pattern the amount of uncertainty it has
is more akin to what it would be if
there were 259 equally likely outcomes
you could think of it like this it knows
borks is not the answer same with yortz
and zoro and zorus so it's a little less
uncertain than it was in the previous
case this number of bits will be smaller
and if i keep playing the game i'm
refining this down with a couple guesses
that are apropos of what i would like to
explain here
by the fourth guess if you look over at
its top picks you can see it's no longer
just maximizing the entropy so at this
point there's technically seven
possibilities but the only ones with a
meaningful chance are dorms and words
and you can see it ranks choosing both
of those above all of these other values
that strictly speaking would give more
information
the very first time i did this i just
added up these two numbers to measure
the quality of each guess which actually
worked better than you might suspect but
it really didn't feel systematic and i'm
sure there's other approaches people
could take but here's the one i landed
on if we're considering the prospect of
a next guest like in this case words
what we really care about is the
expected score of our game if we do that
and to calculate that expected score we
say what's the probability that words is
the actual answer which at the moment it
describes 58 to so we say with a 58
chance our score in this game would be
four
and then with the probability of one
minus that 58 percent um our score will
be more than that four how much more we
don't know but we can estimate it based
on how much uncertainty there's likely
to be once we get to that point
specifically at the moment there's 1.44
bits of uncertainty
if we guess words it's telling us the
expected information we'll get is 1.27
bits so if we guess words this
difference represents how much
uncertainty we're likely to be left with
after that happens what we need is some
kind of function which i'm calling f
here that associates this uncertainty
with an expected score and the way i
went about this was to just plot a bunch
of the data from previous games based on
version one of the bot to say hey what
was the actual score after various
points with certain very measurable
amounts of uncertainty for example these
data points here that are sitting above
a value that's around like 8.7 or so are
saying for some games after a point at
which there were 8.7 bits of uncertainty
it took two guesses to get the final
answer for other games it took three
guesses for other games it took four
guesses
if we shift over to the left here all
the points over zero are saying whenever
there's zero bits of uncertainty which
is to say there's only one possibility
then the number of guesses required is
always just one which is reassuring
whenever there was one bit of
uncertainty meaning it was essentially
just down to two possibilities then
sometimes it required one more guess
sometimes it required two more guesses
and so on and so forth here
maybe a slightly easier way to visualize
this data is to bucket it together and
take averages
for example this bar here saying among
all the points where we had one bit of
uncertainty on average the number of new
guesses required was about 1.5
and the bar over here saying among all
of the different games were at some
point the uncertainty was a little above
4 bits which is like narrowing it down
to 16 different possibilities then on
average it requires a little more than
two guesses from that point forward and
from here i just did a regression to fit
a function that seemed reasonable to
this and remember the whole point of
doing any of that is so that we can
quantify this intuition that the more
information we gain from a word the
lower the expected score will be
so with this as version 2.0 if we go
back and we run the same set of
simulations having it play against all 2
315 possible wordle answers how does it
do
well in contrast to our first version
it's definitely better which is
reassuring all said and done the average
is around 3.6 although unlike the first
version there are a couple times that it
loses and requires more than six in this
circumstance presumably because there's
times when it's making that trade-off to
actually go for the goal rather than
maximizing information
so can we do better than 3.6
we definitely can now i said at the
start that it's most fun to try not
incorporating the true list of wordle
answers into the way that it builds its
model but if we do incorporate it the
best performance i could get was around
3.43
so if we try to get more sophisticated
than just using word frequency data to
choose this prior distribution this 3.43
probably gives a max at how good we
could get with that or at least how good
i could get with that that best
performance essentially just uses the
ideas that i've been talking about here
but it goes a little farther like it
does a search for the expected
information two steps forward rather
than just one originally i was planning
on talking more about that but i realize
we've actually gone quite long as it is
the one thing i'll say is after doing
this two-step search and then running a
couple sample simulations in the top
candidates so far for me at least it's
looking like crane is the best opener
who would have guessed
also if you use the true word list to
determine your space of possibilities
then the uncertainty you start with is a
little over 11 bits and it turns out
just from a brute force search the
maximum possible expected information
after the first two guesses is around 10
bits which suggests that best case
scenario after your first two guesses
with perfectly optimal play you'll be
left with around one bit of uncertainty
which is the same as being down to two
possible guesses but i think it's fair
and probably pretty conservative to say
that you could never possibly write an
algorithm that gets this average as low
as three because with the words
available to you there's simply not room
to get enough information after only two
steps to be able to guarantee the answer
in the third slot every single time
without fail
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you